wie man minecraft kisten abschließen
kann
hallöchen meine lieben freunde und
herzlich willkommen zu einer neuen folge
von dem minecraft commands ich muss
leider ganz leise sprechen und flüstern
was macht dieses hühnchen ich war gerade
noch so extrem lautes ist gerade 12 uhr
und ich muss morgen wieder früh
aufstehen
aber ich habe gerade noch bei mir gesagt
und ich hab voll vergessen dass das ja
hausfriedensbruch ist wohl ist das
hausfriedensbruch ich bin mir gar nicht
mal so sicher aber ich habe auf jeden
fall grad noch gesagt meine
mitbewohnerin hier nicht mitbewohnerin
aber meine nachbarn und so die tun mir
alle migranten mega tue mir gerade alle
mega light deswegen möchte ich jetzt
nicht allzu laut sein des blöden würde
ich wieder sondern folgen da kann ich ja
überhaupt nicht reden aber ich glaube
das spiegelt auch schon wieder die
uhrzeit eigentlich schon wieder wieder
viele freunde ich bin jetzt ruhig also
ich hab mit fünf geile commands
rausgesucht die e mail geschickt hat
über das commands formular was oben in
der beschreibung verlinkt ist da sind
heute wieder so krank geile command aber
ich weiß nicht wie ich finde immer jeden
command geil aber wir nehmen es immer
als wenige jetzt erst mal als ersten
command song command um so ein bisschen
rein zu kommen so eine simple sache
einfach bringt immer noch sorry wegen
der tonspur falls die teilweise so ein
bisschen aus schwingt und teilweise ist
sie dann wieder ganz leise oder so ich
bin das zurzeit als in einem fixen wegen
den blöden nachbarn bei die teilweise
echt richtig viel bohren aber hier ist
mal command nummer eins zu gesendet
wurde von einer person die anonym
bleiben möchte und zwar ist es einfach
ein schneemann der auf einem pferd
reitet das ist kummer nummer eins ein
schneemann auf einem pferd es ist ein
schneemann aufnehmen ich lebte keine
ahnung freunde das ist halt wirklich
einfach ein schneemann auf einem pferd
ich glaube dazu brauche ich nicht mehr
sagen als wir machen dirk wahrte mit dem
2 4 hektar auf jeden fall viel geiler
ist weil der erste verhältnis immer so
ein bisschen um reinzukommen umliegende
scheiße 15
der zweite effekt ist auch eine total
simple sache allerdings eine coole sache
und zwei mal das mikro seien kleine
stückchen mit zurück dass mich ein
bisschen besser an der face käme seht
und zwar bot mir das zugesendet von
tipp24 ganz einfach dass man die world
border setzen kann ich mache jetzt mal
so und jetzt habe ich hier hinten
beispielsweise die world water gesetzter
fliegen
schnell mal hin und da seht ihr schon
wenn ich jetzt hier bin ich bin
selbstverständlich im creative mord und
kann deswegen auch hier rein fliegen bzw
nicht wieder raus fliegen also rein
fliegen natürlich ist immer möglich aber
rausfliegen jetzt nicht und damit habe
ich jetzt quasi hier diese world border
gesetzt die wird einfach hier immer so
gesetzt ich hab keine ahnung wieso genau
hier immer so irgendwie x0 z 0 und y
irgendwie 100 oder irgendwie so um den
dreh beziehungsweise 0 0 und höfen keine
ahnung höhe 64 oder so da wird dir
einfach immer das board man kann
natürlich auch irgendwelche koordinaten
eingeben aber ich habe jetzt einfach mal
hier bauen lassen weil der command
einfach einfacher ist also der command
ist einfach / world border set 50 ist
einfach die weite hier das heißt wenn
ich rein theoretisch mal sowas machen
würde wenn ich jetzt beispielsweise mal
szenen packen würde
seht ihr schon die world order wird
jetzt verringert und die einst ihr am
ende sehen ist beispielsweise einfach
ich mach das jetzt mal auf 5 und
schreibe hier mal eine 10 hin
dann seht ihr schon die wakeboarder
brauche jetzt zehn sekunden und auf
diese stelle zurück zu gehen das heißt
ich kann das ganze auch mit sekunde 100
machen oder so dann wird ihr halt extrem
lange brauchen um auf diese weise hier
zurückzugeben und jetzt ist hier quasi
12345 also hier in halver daran halber
und in der mitte vier blöcke und hier
komme ich da nicht raus beziehungsweise
ich komme nur auf diesen halben blog
raus und damit kann ich quasi einfach
eine world border sätzen wie ich hier
rauskomme sei jetzt mal dahingestellt
aber das wird mir zu gesendet von 84 und
so funktioniert das ganze in cap tiff
übrigens für alle dies eventuell
interessiert hat und ich glaube ich muss
mich einfach töten sonst was mache ich
komme ich aus der fucking world water
raus weil es einfach mal eine neue map
gemacht und der zieht ist wieder sehr
sehr cool falls ihr den ziel haben
wollte ich dich spor nicht immer auf
solchen apps keine ahnung finde ich auch
schon wieder recht cool dahinter sind
einfach so kürbisse das ist nichts
einfach so eine insel im niemandsland
für diesen command brauche ich erstmal
einen command lockt das gfp command
block dann packe ich hier mal ein
command login
und da muss dieser befehl rein dieser
befehl set block und wenn ich da jetzt
beispielsweise einfach mal einen hebel
nehme und so machen sie schon da wird
jetzt ein red storm blog gespannt da
dort einer gespannten welche das ganze
jetzt einfach mal so machen so und jetzt
habe ich nämlich eine clock erstellt und
jetzt
kommt nämlich der zweite befehl dazu und
zwar gehe ich jetzt mal eben ganz kurz
hier wieder in mein formular ein
und jetzt kommt nämlich der der command
mehr oder weniger der eigentlich von dem
command hier so handeln soll
gesendet wird man das ganze übrigens von
bruno der hat mir das nicht wirklich
zugesagt sondern haben ein video
geschickt wo das ganze gezeigt wurde das
heißt ich setze hier einen command login
und packe hier diesem gefühl rein und
jetzt seht ihr schon im chat die ganze
zeit steht ihr blog platziert wenn ich
mal hoch oder runter scrollen schon das
geht die ganze zeit so weit rechts
kramer wir wieder so ein moment ich kann
noch jemand kann ich nicht mal irgendwie
so ein bisschen
ich kann ich weiter hoch freuen wenn ich
jetzt ich zeige euch das mal so wenn ich
hier hallo rein schreibe das wird extrem
steil hoch gepumpt und jetzt kommt
nämlich der eigentlich effect endlich
mal und wenn ich jetzt nämlich einen tnt
hier einfach mal anzünde schaut euch
jetzt mal an das ist ein stinknormales
tnt hier kann ich noch mal weg man gar
nicht hinsetzen vielleicht auch an finde
man kann das ganze auch noch viel viel
krasser machen allerdings ist das erst
mal so der effekt den ndr command den er
mit zugesendet hat also wenn ich das
ganze so aufbauen kann ich da machen
dass mein tnt schaden extrem riesig wird
ihr seht jetzt die ganze zeit im chat
blog platziert das werdet ihr jetzt auch
bei den nächsten command sehen es tut
mir leid aber das ist halt einfach nicht
zu vermeiden nach diesem command ich
werde wahrscheinlich in der nächsten
folge dann nochmal eine erweiterte
version davon darstellen und zwar wurde
es in einem anderen video gezeigt wie
man einen tornado damit erstellen kann
wenn ihr das wollt ist das meiner
nächsten folge mache dann schreibe es in
die kommentare oder leicht das video
zeigt es mir irgendwie weil es kann auch
sein dass einige meilen hey du hast das
jetzt vorgestellte muss es nicht normal
vorstellen krassere variante nur das ist
ein bisschen komplizierter mit dem
tornado da muss man noch andere commands
ein geben uns ein bisschen komplizierter
würde ich dann beim nächsten mal machen
als neuen command wenn ihr es denn haben
wollt zeigt man das einfach irgendwie
und das wollten erstmal zugesendet von
bruce labruce 0 keine ahnung und dann
machen wir direkt weiter mit command
nummer 1 ich habe nichts verändert an
diesem sieht aber hier ist einfach
wirklich so eine insel die geht einfach
hier so hoch da geht einfach sonst ding
hier hoch wenn das so wäre wäre das
perfekt nahezu da müsst ihr hier noch
ein sand block hin und dann dann wäre
das einfach so eine perfekte strecke
auch freunde ich mache jetzt mal eben
schnell noch den chat hieraus macht man
eben der kraft einfach weise niemals
einfach und jetzt kommen wir zu dem
befehl den wahrscheinlich schon im titel
gesehen habt und
den alle gewartet haben und zwar habe
ich herausgefunden bzw wurden mehr
gesendet wie man minecraft kisten
abschließen kann das ist eigentlich
extrem simpel und 260 einfach mal diesen
command locker hin dann eben einen hebel
und dann packe ich hier diesen command
rein und zwar / set blog dass ein blog
platziert wird welle 2 also zwei blöcke
weiter vorne dann ein ganz normaler
wähler also hör auf einer höhe und von
der anderen axt auf einer höhe
minecraft doppelpunkt test also eine
kiste 4 replays und dann lockt die und
dieses lok liegt jetzt auf jeden fall
einfach mal auf fertig drücke hier auf
den schalter drauf dann sehen wir schon
wir haben hier eine kiste
wir können das ganze jetzt hier wieder
abbauen und wenn ich jetzt nämlich auf
diese kiste drauf klickt ihr seht ihr
schon wisst verschlossen ich klicke
drauf ist verschlossen das seht ihr ja
da unten
allerdings kann ich die mit einem
gewissen gegenstand öffnen zwar hole ich
mir darf jetzt erstmal den amboss und
ich könnte mir dafür auch beispielsweise
mal hier so einen haken holen weil ich
finde der haken sieht am meisten aus wie
ein schlüssel und zwar muss sich diesem
schlüssel jetzt einfach key nennen so
freunde ich habe jetzt hier dieses ding
das heißt sie und wenn ich hier mit
rechts drauf mache dann kann ich die
truhe öffnen wenn ich dann allerdings
mit einem amboss rächt sich darauf mache
dann steht da ist verschlossen ich
könnte allerdings auch einen theoretisch
den amboss einfach malki nennen dann
habe ich hier den amboss die heißt dann
kann ich hier mit auch öffnen
hiermit öffnen aber mit meiner hand
nicht weil meine hand heißt quasi nicht
und das ist quasi eine möglichkeit mit
der man in minecraft kisten verschließen
kann ist extrem cool ich glaube das
ganze funktioniert auch noch mit öfen
crafting table türen meine ich auch noch
irgendwie diesen fall türen auch alle
sachen mit dem man mehr oder weniger
interagieren kann das ist dann so
ähnlich wie bei wie bei leben mit den
kisten dass man die halt auch nicht so
öffnen kann von anderen leuten das wird
mir zu gesendet von einer person die
auch anonym bleiben möchte und man muss
quasi einfach nur diesen kohle diesen
command blog nehmen und so eine kiste
sportlers mit dem command den ich euch
gezeigt habe und dann einfach
irgendeinen gegenstand in den namen
verwandeln wo ihr diesen locker
eingegeben habt und das findet ihr auch
alles in der beschreibung dann machen
wir es weiter mit dem letzten command
der letzte kommunist wieder eine sehr
simple sache und zwar wird er mir zu
gerne von paul ehre 282 und zwar ist es
einfach ein unbesiegbarer ändert und
zwar einfach dieser commander christel
riding ender dragon also
wir haben damit jetzt wir einander
drachen erschaffen und der wird geritten
von einem ender kristall und der tender
drache denkt sich natürlich immer ja um
meine energie aufzufüllen nehme ich
natürlich einen ender christel immer mit
und mit dem täter dann quasi auf bzw er
nimmt die nicht mit sondern er fliegt im
enthalt quasi immer zum ende christel
hin damit er quasi da seine energie
aufladen kann
allerdings wenn er einen righteous seht
ihr schon wenn ich den boxer seht ihr
oben die lebensanzeige ich boxing hat
mit einem diamant schwert und ich boxe
ist beispielsweise normal wenn der mal
wiederkommen würde der pizza der kommt
jetzt alle das sieht aus als wäre riesig
groß weil er so über dem wer guckt jetzt
seht ihr oben da der legt sich wieder
auf natürlich wenn ich jetzt ein schwert
hätte wie das letztens wo ich euch
gezeigt hatte das krasseste schwert mit
allen möglichen verwandlungen fr nicht
verwandlungen mit allen möglichen
effekten drauf und so war man einfach
mit einem hit den ender drachen töten
kann dann ist das ganze natürlich
selbstverständlich möglich weil er sich
dann quasi nicht aufladen kann sondern
direkt tot ist aber so wenn ich in boxen
ist das einfach oben direkt wieder
aufgeladen also mehr oder weniger im
survival mode ein komplett gar nicht
besiegt bahre ändert recken außer man
hätte halt wirklich dieses krasse
schwert dann wäre es möglich aber ich
denke ihr wisst was euch zeigen möchte
ich habe diesen effekt als letzten
genommen nicht weil er extrem
spektakulär ist eigentlich gar nicht so
spektakulär bzw diesem format ich
versuche mich dann mal mit dem command
infekt aber ganz einfach weil der ändert
meine welt zerstört und deswegen wollte
ich dir nicht als erster dran nehmen
weil der lette der alles kaputt gemacht
und so weiter und so fort aber damit
würde ich sagen meine lieben freunde
möchte eine rose möchte nicht ok damit
würde ich sagen war es dass das was ist
das heißt damit war es ist das war das
lawa ich schon wieder aber das sieht
sehr schön aus sie macht mir das
bestimmt nicht kaputte schöne ambiente
hier wenn das richtig coole man bei
diesen komischen blumen blümchen inseln
und somit dem crusader das super wollt
ihr übrigens mal dass ich mal wieder ein
top 5 video mache ich habe er bisher nur
über die top-5 creepy shader gemacht
wenn ich es wollte sich mal über meine
top 5 liegt darf nicht so laut sein
deswegen schreibe immer so komische
kermit der frosch
wenn ihr mal sondern an der macht echt
alles kaputt also wenn ihr so ein video
haben wollte über die top 5 steht die
ich wirklich gut finde
dann könnt ihr mir das auch einfach mal
die kommentare schreiben keine ahnung
ich möchte mit euch in der ag oder schon
einmal durchgeführt
jedenfalls ist es wieder vorbei ich
würde mich über eine bewertung freuen
weil es ein klick ist und dann sehen wir
uns in einem nächsten commands video
wieder oder in
anderen video wieder oder morgen in
leben mit sturm waffe oder morgen im
real life video hier ist immer noch
alter ich will dich geh doch mal rein
mal schauen wie viele ändern
okay ganz elementar von mit letzten
blocks hab ich